can't go out
I'm sick
as she battled bowel cancer Dame Deborah
James campaign tirelessly she raised
awareness about the illness on social
media documenting her journey and spoke
about the highs and lows with friends on
a podcast
ever since the moment Deb was diagnosed
back in 2016 it's just been her mission
to try and educate people and you know
via all the silly videos on Instagram
the dancing videos the Pooh costume it
was all about educating people there are
thousands and thousands of people who
are not exaggerating there are thousands
and thousands of people that are alive
because of Deb
in her final months she raised over
seven million pounds for cancer research
and was honored with a damehood Deborah
James became a national figure and
encouraged others to get checked out the
way that she approached talking about
bowel cancer it took away the stigma she
saved my life without a shadow of a
doubt without her
um I wouldn't be here today I don't
think in the weeks that followed her
death bowel cancer referrals hit an
all-time high these figures show just
how much of an impact she made
between May and July 170 500 people were
referred for bowel cancer checks that's
up by 30 000 compared to the same time
last year and a rise of nearly 80 000
from two years ago the number of people
checking the NHS website for symptoms
also increased by nearly two hundred
thousand
the prognosis of bowel cancer changes
significantly depending on when it's
first caught so if you catch bowel
cancer at the earlier stage what we call
stage one over nine in ten people
survive for five years or more if you
catch cancer at the later stage stage
four fewer than one in ten people
survived for five years or more so
that's a really really Stark difference
[Music]
be like this Deborah James brought bowel
cancer to the Forefront of conversation
she undoubtedly saved countless lives
and has left behind a lasting Legacy
Aisha zahid Sky News